Wie ist eigentlich der Fußball besetzt mit weiblichen Führungspersonen? Das untersucht unter anderem Fußball kann mehr und da habe ich jetzt die Geschäftsführerin hier im Rasenfunk. Julia Möhn ist hier. Jetzt geht's los.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Dadurch, dass es eben die Bezahlung so gering ist, es waren 100 Euro im Monat, die ich ein bisschen als Fahrtgeld bekommen hab, hab ich halt immer noch einen Nebenjob dabei gehabt, neben dem Studium noch und dann noch Fußball. Und das war eben ein so immens hoher zeitlicher Aufwand.
Unseren anderen Damenmannschaften steht nur der Aschplatz zur Verfügung. Dabei hat Fortuna aber einen großen Rasenplatz, wo wir Frauen aber gar nicht trainieren dürfen. Der ist nur für die Profi-Mannschaft der Herren.
Und deswegen müssen wir an dem System arbeiten und nicht an den Frauen, dass sich wirklich da auch etwas verändert.
Das Tribünengespräch.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, Kennerinnen und Kenner von euch, die werden mitbekommen haben. Dieses Intro, das gab es schon mal im Rasenfunk. Ja, das ist das Intro zur Sendung Frauenfeindliche Strukturen im Profifußball. Und ein bisschen ist es nämlich auch unser Überthema heute. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid und schön, dass Julia Möhn hier ist. Hallo, Julia.
Guten Morgen. Hallo, Max.
Du bist Geschäftsführerin bei Fußball kann mehr. Lass uns mal ganz am Anfang anfangen. Was ist denn Fußball kann mehr?
Genau, ganz am Anfang muss man sagen, bin ich schon nur Chronistin, weil ich nicht am Anfang dabei war. Das ist als Initiative gegründet worden von neun Frauen, darunter sehr prominente Frauen aus dem Fußball, wie Viviana Steinhaus, Claudia Neumann, Gabi Papenburg, Almut Schult. Und die haben sich über eine Reportage von Claudia Neumann während Corona Frauen im Fußball gefunden. Man ist ja dann schon immer ganz erstaunt, dass sie sich nicht davor gefunden haben. Aber genaue Netzwerken ist auch ein wirkliches Thema und haben dann festgestellt, dass sie bestimmte Erfahrungen, obwohl sie an sehr unterschiedlichen Stellen der Fußballindustrie, der Fußballbranche gearbeitet haben, dass die ihnen gemein sind. Und da ging es um tatsächlich Diskriminierungserfahrungen, aber auch um dieses Gefühl, dass wir die ganze Sache nicht wirklich voranbringen und dass Fußball nicht das Potenzial ausschöpft, wirklich für alle da zu sein. Und daraus sind Forderungen entstanden. Wir haben acht und auf denen basiert unsere Arbeit heute noch. Unter anderem handelt es von Quote, von der Sanktionierung, von Sexismus und Diskriminierung, von fairer Bezahlung. Und dann sind diese Forderungen mit einem großen Medienecho veröffentlicht worden. Ich glaube auch ein bisschen, weil damals der deutsche Fußball in seiner größten Krise war, der DFB. Und man ist, die sind zuerst so wahrgenommen worden als Antagonistinnen des Fußballs. Und dann sind dann relativ schnell zu dem Punkt gekommen, zu sagen, das ist eine relativ komfortabler Position, aber keine, in dem wir auch daran mitwirken können, diese Dinge wirklich zu ändern. Also wir wurden dann immer wieder angerufen und zu sagen, was läuft da falsch, aber wie läuft es richtig? Deshalb haben sie dann angefangen, sich zu überlegen, wie kann man aus dieser Initiative mehr machen? Und daraus ist dann eine gemeinnützige GmbH geworden, die tatsächlich berät, wir beraten Bundesligaklubs und Klubs der 2. Liga, wir beraten Verbände und sportnahe Unternehmen, wir haben mit Sky gearbeitet zum Beispiel, mit Hops. Und sie dabei zu unterstützen, ein Status quo zu gucken, wie sind die Frauen in dem Unternehmen, wie sind die Frauen in den Klubs, wo sind sie? Und wie kann man tatsächlich dafür, was kann man dafür tun, um diese Organisation so umzubauen, dass diese Frauen dort ihr volles Potenzial entfalten können?
Das heißt, so ein bisschen hat sich Fußball kann mehr weiterentwickelt von der Botschaft, Fußball kann mehr, verbunden eben mit diesen acht Forderungen hin zu einem, ja ist es dann Consulting, das ihr da macht? Wie würdest du das beschreiben?
Also das ist auf jeden Fall ein wichtiger Teil davon. Worüber wir heute sprechen, ist immer noch der Teil auch Aufklärung und Öffentlichkeitsarbeit für dieses Thema. Also wir sind auch nach wie vor würde ich sagen Lobbyistinnen dieses Themas und könnte man glaube ich auch sagen Kompetenzzentrum für dieses Thema. Aber auf jeden Fall ist ein Teil davon geworden die Clubs, die für dieses Thema offen sind. Und wir sind ja auch nicht die einzigen, muss man sagen, die sich mit diesen Themen beschäftigen. Aber die halt sagen, so wir möchten diese, möchten das angehen. Wir brauchen dafür strategische Unterstützung und das sind seit der Gründung von Fußball kann mehr. Arbeiten wir mit Stuttgart, mit Frankfurt und mit Werder Bremen. Und wir arbeiten projektbezogen mit anderen Clubs zusammen jetzt seit letztem Jahr zum Beispiel mit Hoffenheim und dem HSV. Und haben Nürnberg beraten zu einem Teilbereich. Also das kommt so, dass wir merken, dass einige Clubs sofort irgendwie sagen, in dem Feld brauchen wir Unterstützung. Und bei anderen Clubs ist es so, dass man auch wirklich ihnen einfach selber noch die Informationen fehlen. Wie könnten sie diese Themen bei sich im Club angehen?
Wenn du versuchen müsstest, Fußball kann mehr in einem Satz zusammenzufassen, was euer Ziel ist, wofür ihr einsteht, wie würdet er lauten?
Wir setzen uns für Chancengerechtigkeit im Fußball ein und wir setzen uns dafür ein, dass der Fußball das Versprechen einlöst, was er gibt, nämlich die Gesellschaft so zu repräsentieren, wie er das für sich in Anspruch nimmt.
Und ist es dann eine richtige Beobachtung meinerseits, dass ihr euch da erstmal auf das Thema Geschlechtediversität konzentriert oder sind auch noch, weil die Repräsentanz der Gesellschaft wären ja ganz viele Aspekte oder fasst das vielleicht zu kurz?
Nein, das ist richtig. Wir sind gestartet, um vor allem in einem ersten Schritt, und wir sehen schon, dass das ein langer Schritt ist, uns einzusetzen, vor allem für Geschlechterdiversität. Mir ist ganz wichtig, dass es da, wie gesagt, auch Menschen gibt, die auch in diesem Feld arbeiten, also zum Beispiel in diesem Jahr neu gegründet Roots, Football Against Racism, die wirklich auch, was das angeht, eine hohe Kompetenz und, glaube ich, ein ganz wichtiges Thema damit etabliert haben. Es gibt Kick-In als Beratung zur Inklusion. Es gibt The League als Netzwerkoorganisation für, auch nochmal neben den Flinter-Bewegungen, auch nochmal ganz viel Non-Binary-Menschen im Sport. Also ich finde es wichtig, dass man nicht denkt, wir sind nun die Einzigen, die diese Themen voranbringen. Ich glaube, der spezifische Zugang von Fußball kann mehr, ist schon einer, der von vornherein auch aus dem Fußball herauskommt, weniger aus einer Außenseiterperspektive, weil die Menschen, die es gegründet haben, haben eigentlich fast alle eine Gegenwart und oder eine Vergangenheit im organisierten Sport. Katja Kraus, die das ganz entschieden mit vorantreibt, auch heute noch war die erste Frau im Vorstand eines Bundesliga-Clubs beim HSV. Sollte Bibi-Jana Steinhaus, ich muss jetzt nicht diese gesamten Lobeshymnen sprechen, aber es sind viele Frauen, die die ersten waren und zum Teil leider dann auch die ersten geblieben sind. Das ist ja eben genau das, was man ändern muss. Es reicht ja nicht, dass man diese Rekorde bejubelt und sagt, okay, zum ersten Mal hat es geschafft, X, Y, Z, sondern es geht darum, dann die Strukturen so anzupassen, dass es halt für die Zweite, die Dritte und dann alle Weiteren einfacher ist. Und das ist, glaube ich, der größte Antrieb, den wir haben, den die Menschen haben, die es gegründet haben und der Beirat, mit dem wir heute arbeiten, der tatsächlich fast 50-50 besetzt ist, auch mit Männern.
Und wenn ihr dann mit Vereinen zusammenarbeitet, dann vermute ich, wird doch eine der ersten Fragen oft sein, ja, warum sollten wir das überhaupt, dieses Thema so hoch hängen? Was glaubst du, geht denn dem Fußball verloren, dadurch, dass er so wenig divers ist?
Also, ich würde das immer so beantworten, dass für den Fußball, glaube ich, in der Tat eines der Hauptprobleme ist, dass er das nicht selber sieht. Also, dass dieses Potenzial für Menschen, die ein bisschen von außen drauf schauen und diese Unternehmen, die es ja sind, es sind kleine und mittelständische Unternehmen, Bundesliga-Klubs von 30 Mitarbeitern bis 1000 Mitarbeitenden, dass die eben sich nicht in eine Konkurrenz setzen zu vergleichbaren Unternehmen, die von den Führungsstrukturen her professioneller sind, die stärker auf eigene Talententwicklung achten und die natürlich auch KPIs haben bei solchen Themen wie Innovation, wie tatsächlich Teamzusammenhalt. Diese ganzen Dinge sind für den Fußball immer noch nicht regulär. Und das ist, glaube ich, die größte Herausforderung, dass der Fußball sich relativ fernhalten kann oder immer noch fernhält von diesen Themen. Weil wenn man dann darauf guckt, dann ist das wohl dokumentiert, die wirtschaftliche Kraft von Diversität. Und man muss auch sagen, ich finde es immer erstaunlich, dass Menschen, die zugegebenermaßen etwas weiter außerhalb dieser Bubble stehen, denken, dass keine Frauen im Fußball arbeiten. Also keiner dieser Bundesligaklubs hat weniger als 15 Prozent Frauen. Die meisten haben zwischen 20 und 30 Prozent Frauen unter ihren Mitarbeitenden. Das heißt, wenn wir auf diese Unternehmensstrukturen gucken, dann heißt es nicht, da gibt es gar keine Frauen, sondern es gibt keine Frauen ab einem bestimmten Hierarchie-Level. Wir sehen halt keine im Top-Management, wir sehen relativ wenig in den Aufsichtsräten, wir sehen relativ wenig dann auf dieser zweiten Führungsstruktur, die wir jetzt Direct Reports nennen, also die direkt an die Geschäftsführung oder den Vorstand berichtet. Darunter gibt es selbstverständlich sehr viele Frauen. Das ist, und ich glaube auch das verschiebt mal ein bisschen das Beurteilungsbild, was wir merken, wenn wir dann in Medien sind, dass sie uns sagen, ja wieso jetzt denn auch noch, wieso wollen sie denn jetzt auch noch in den Fußball? Wir wollen nicht in den Fußball, das ist ein Prinzip von Eisberg. Also man sieht diese Frauen nun nicht, aber die sind schon da. Also es geht dann darum, ihnen die gleichen Chancen zu geben, auch die Position zu erreichen, wie den Männern.
Und gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich den etwas schwerer zu messenden Effekt, dass wenn du in gewissen Hierarchieebenen keine Frauen hast, dass dann Frauen der unteren Ebenen an eine gläserne Decke stoßen und dann vielleicht auch sogar das Unternehmen, in dem Fall dann den Fußballverein, verlassen, bevor sie überhaupt die Möglichkeit gehabt hätten, da oben reinzustoßen. Und dann sagen die Fußballvereine, ja, aber hier bewirbt sich ja nie jemand. Und vielleicht haben sie aber schon 20 potenzielle, ganz tolle Führungskräfte verloren, einfach weil da niemand hingeguckt hat und man das nicht gesehen hat. Und auch deshalb veröffentlicht ihr ja jetzt zum zweiten Mal schon euren Jahresbericht, der eben erst mal versucht zu messen. Und Daten zu erfassen. Kannst du noch mal kurz erklären, warum das überhaupt wichtig ist, erst mal Daten zu haben?
Ja, also du hast vorhin erzählt, dass das tatsächlich für dich auch ein Hörer immer auswertet, wie viele weibliche Gäste du hast und wie viele männliche Gäste. Das klingt ja ganz einfach, aber es ist total wichtig. Also einer der erfolgreichsten Projekte in diesem Feld ist das 5050 Project der BBC. Die haben damit angefangen zu sagen, wie viele ihre Expertinnen und wie viele ihre Experten haben die eigentlich on air. Also wie viele, lassen sie da zu Wort kommen, die Frauen sind wie viele, die sind Männer und waren selber am Anfang total entsetzt darüber, wie diese Zahl ausfällt. Die war halt so was wie bei 30, 70. Und dann haben sie sich gesagt, okay, aber natürlich, wir bilden die Gesellschaft ab, hier muss es 5050 sein. Und haben dann angefangen, es zu messen und es mit Zielen zu hinterlegen. Und dieses Modell, wir haben, wir erheben Zahlen, machen sie sichtbar, setzen uns darauf neue Zahlen, ist eigentlich auch das, was hinter dem Jahresbericht liegt. Wir orientieren uns da an dem Allbright-Bericht, der Allbright-Stiftung, die machen seit 2016 Allbright-Berichte, die sich das angucken für DAX-Unternehmen. Also wie sind dort die Vorstände und wir sind da die Aufsichtsräte zusammengesetzt. Und Sie haben uns mal gesagt, als Sie 2016 gestartet sind, waren die Zahlen vergleichbar im Fußball, was ich hoffnungsvoll finde, weil inzwischen sind sie dort nicht mehr. Auch wenn jetzt Deutschland immer noch nicht grandios abschneidet, schneiden sie doch deutlich besser ab, als sie eben 2016 abschnitten.
Gibt es denn jetzt mehr Frauen als Thomasse in DAX-Vorständen?
Ja, das gibt es tatsächlich. Ich glaube, es ist immer noch...
Das ist ein enges Engename.
Ich glaube, man findet immer noch neue Vornamen, Konstellationen, wo man immer merkt, okay, also wir sind da auch nicht überm Berg, aber wir sind den Berg einen entschieden Schritt hochgegangen. So können halt diese Berichte etwas sichtbar machen, aber es bleibt halt nicht beim sichtbar machen. Es kann nicht sein, dass wir es uns angucken und sagen, oh, sondern aus diesen Zahlen müssen dann Ziele werden, was wir dann damit machen. Und wir haben das dann im letzten Jahr zum ersten Mal gemacht und haben gesagt, okay, uns interessiert, wie sind denn eigentlich wirklich diese Gremien zusammengesetzt? Was sind das für Menschen, die dort sind, also fürs Top-Management? Wir nennen das so, weil es halt tatsächlich die Governance-Modelle von Bundesliga-Klubs durchaus unterschiedlich sind. Es gibt EVs, es gibt KOKGs und deshalb haben wir uns darauf geeinigt, das Top-Management so zu benennen. Es kann aber eine Geschäftsführung sein, Vorstand und Präsidium sein, je nach Governance-Modell. Und dann gucken wir uns die Kontrollgremien an. Das ist auch nicht bei allen der Aufsichtsrat. Nicht jeder Club hat einen, fast alle haben aber einen, dann ist es aber auch nicht bei allen. Sind die nicht entscheidend dafür, die Geschäftsführung des Top-Managements einzusetzen und zu entlassen? So ist die Definition. Und wir haben noch anders als All-By-Type gesagt, okay, wir möchten uns auch noch die Ebene darunter anschauen. Auch ein bisschen aus dem, was ich eben gesagt habe, weil wir wissen, dass Frauen in Fußballklubs arbeiten. Uns aber natürlich, dafür müssen wir ja nicht diese Erhebung machen. Wir wissen ja, dass in dem Top-Management der 36 Clubs wirklich wenig Frauen sind. Das heißt, wenn wir es nur bei diesen beiden Ebenen belassen haben, wäre das eine sehr frustrierende Erzählung geworden. Wo man jetzt auch nicht irgendwie sagen kann, okay, da ist wahnsinnig viel Dynamik drin. Das war schon im letzten Jahr klar. Insofern war uns wichtig, das darunter zu zeigen, um eben auch, was wir schon die ganze Zeit machen, auf Positivbeispiele zu finden, auch wirklich Clubs zu finden, die halt bestimmte Themen, wie du eben gesagt hast, da bewirbt sich ja keine Frau, schon angegangen sind und anders gelöst haben für sich.
Und kannst du mal erklären, wie geht dir dann bei der Erstellung dieses Jahresberichts vor?
Wir versenden eine Umfrage an die 36 Clubs, auch jetzt nicht atinfoatholsteinkiel.de, wie du dir vorstellen kannst, sondern das sind natürlich der Versuch, die richtigen Menschen dabei zu erreichen. Also Personalverantwortliche in Kombination mit eben Top-Management, weil uns auch klar ist, dass solche Sachen immer green-gesigned werden müssen von dann den entscheidenden Positionen. Und dort werden Dinge abgefragt, so Zahlen erhoben. Uns ist auch wichtig, dass wir abgesehen vom Top-Management keine personalisierten Daten erheben. Also das heißt, im Top-Management fragen wir auch so was ab, wie Alter, akademischen Hintergrund, Ausbildungshintergrund, die halt dann auch natürlich zuortenbar wären, wenn man nur zwei Menschen hat in einer Geschäftsführung. Und der eine hat diese Ausbildung, der andere hat diese Ausbildung. Da ist es klar verortbar. Bei den Direct Reports machen wir das nicht, weil da man schon in den Bereich Datenschutz reingeht und das ist nichts, wo wir irgendwie sagen, okay, das ist für uns erstrebenswert. Für uns ist es erstrebenswert, dass wir tatsächlich eine komplette Kohorte präsentieren können. Das ist ja, man ahnt es gar nicht so einfach, weil natürlich ja auch Clubs aus diesen 36 ja rausfallen. Und im letzten Jahr, als wir das zum ersten Mal gemacht haben, haben 32 Clubs teilgenommen, zwei der ersten Liga nicht und zwei der zweiten Liga nicht. Und dann ist das natürlich schon ein bisschen anspruchsvoller. Dann musst du halt immer relativ ausführlich erklären, deine Zahlen. Musst du immer sagen, okay, wir haben 32, innerhalb der 32 sind so und so viele Frauen. Diese vier fehlen, Eigenrecherche hat ergeben. Und deshalb war für uns in diesem Jahr ist wirklich die positivste Nachricht, dass alle 36 teilgenommen haben, unter anderem Leverkusen, die halt im letzten Jahr noch gesagt haben, das möchten sie nicht, haben sich beteiligt. Das ist wirklich schön zu sehen, dass du merkst, okay, der Branche hat, also da ist durchgedrungen, dass es wichtig ist, sich diese Zahlen anzugucken. Und was wir eben auch von Arbeit übernommen haben, gar nicht aus dem Sporthintergrund, sondern tatsächlich von da sind halt Rankings. Also das heißt, der Bericht zeigt, wo sind diese Clubs jeweils, wo landen sie mit ihrem, und das ist ein einfaches Farbschema. Wenn du grün bist, dann hast du 30 Prozent oder mehr Frauen auf dieser Ebene. Wenn du gelb hast, hast du Frauen überhaupt auf dieser Ebene. Und wenn du rot bist, dann hast du keinerlei Frauen auf dieser Ebene. Und dieses einfache Sport-Ranking funktioniert überraschenderweise an Sport ganz gut. Also sie, das haben wir bei dem ersten Bericht gesehen. Es ist interessant für Clubs zu sehen, wo ordnen sie sich ein. Und das ist dann auch wiederum einer der Punkte, wo wir sagen, auch deshalb lohnt dieser Bericht in der Ausfertigung, in der Anfertigung, weil er eben auch Antrieb für Veränderungen sein kann.
Interessantes psychologisches Phänomen, dass man dann irgendwann einfach nicht mehr im roten Bereich liegen möchte, der sehr groß ist bei einzelnen Bereichen. Was mich zu der Frage bringt, der Ergebnisse, die jetzt dann eben dieser Jahresbericht zutage befördert hat. Was sind denn die wichtigsten Erkenntnisse?
Also Stagnation im Top-Management und wirklich, wenn ich Stagnation meine, dann meine ich wirklich exakt Stagnation. Also es waren im letzten Jahr sechs Frauen und es sind in diesem Jahr sechs Frauen. Und sechs Frauen von, wie gesagt, wir haben jetzt das Glück gehabt, alle 36 dabei zu haben. Das gibt auch für jetzt nicht so prozentbegabte Menschen wie mich ganz die schöne Summe von 100 Positionen im Top-Management und davon sind es halt sechs Frauen. Drei davon sind in dem Präsidium von St. Pauli, das geschäftsführend ist. Eine ist bei Heidenheim, eine ist bei Schalke, eine ist bei Heidenheim, Schalke, eine ist bei Werder Bremen. Das sind die sechs. Und das heißt vier Clubs, 32 sind rot. Und wenn wir dann, wir haben auch geguckt in dem Jahr, wie viele Neubesetzungen gab es. Und es gab immerhin im Top-Management 19 Neubesetzungen. Das heißt ja doch immerhin schon fast 20 Prozent dieser Positionen sind in den Jahren jemand anders gegangen. Und davon gab es nur eine Frau, die Luise Gottberg hat im Präsidium von St. Pauli eine andere Frau ersetzt. Und das heißt eigentlich, wenn du dir anguckst, wie hat sich diese DAX-Zahlen, haben sich die eigentlich verändert? Dann haben die sich natürlich vor allem über Neubesetzungen verändert. Logischerweise. Also so. Und da sieht man, das funktioniert noch nicht im Fußball. Also diese 19 Neubesetzungen, dann haben wir uns auch nochmal angeguckt, wie viele davon sind verantwortlich für den Sport. Weil das würde ich jetzt schon sagen, das wird die größte Herausforderung sein, eine Frau als Sportdirektorin für Männerfußball, Sportvorstand im Männerfußball zu haben. Aber das sind acht. Das heißt, von den 19 gibt es 11 Positionen, die relativ reguläre Managementaufgaben sind. Und da merkt man schon, dass da funktioniert offenbar noch so ein sehr starker, ja, man sagt das Confirmation Bias. Also das heißt, dass eine Gruppe sich auch innerhalb der Gruppe daran bestätigt, das kann ja keine Frau machen. Ob ausgesprochen oder unconscious, ist eigentlich fast egal. Es wirkt auf jeden Fall. Das sieht man an diesen Zahlen. Und das sind natürlich die Zahlen, die, wenn wir jetzt gucken, noch mal sagen, ob wir 2016, 2025 an diesen Zahlen muss man was verändern. Diese Neubesetzung, da müssen mehr Frauen sein, weil ansonsten wären wir nicht zweistellig werden.
Wie glaubst du, mit welchen Mitteln wäre es denn wahrscheinlich am effektivsten hier auch etwas zu verändern? Soll es in Satzungsreihen geschrieben werden, wie es ja durchaus bei manchen Bundesligisten jetzt der Fall ist, dass man das anschreibt? Soll es eine Quotenregelung geben? Was glaubst du, wären da die wirksamsten Maßnahmen?
Also, bleiben wir ein bisschen bei den Zahlen und dem Bericht. Ich glaube schon, dass es, wir haben ja geguckt, wie viel von diesen Menschen im Top-Management arbeiten, wie lange schon in den Clubs. Und wie viel haben zum Teil auch eine ehrenamtliche Vorvergangenheit, also bevor sie in diese hauptamtlichen Positionen gekommen sind. Und das geben immerhin 24 Prozent der Menschen unter diesen 100 an, dass sie bereits ehrenamtlich gearbeitet haben. Und fast alle arbeiten schon deutlich länger in den Clubs, als sie diese Positionen haben. Die haben eine, man würde sagen, es ist eine hohe Retention-Quote eigentlich im Fußball. Das heißt, der Haupthebel, den man haben wird, ist, die Frauen selbst in den Clubs durchzuentwickeln. Das heißt, es ist unbedingt wichtig, den eigenen Nachwuchs zu ziehen. Genau, den eigenen Nachwuchs zu ziehen, definitiv. Also das heißt, wirklich das, was halt professionell aufgestellte Unternehmen schon lange haben, Talententwicklungsprogramme, Sponsoring-Programme, Mentoring-Programme, wirklich zu schauen, wo habe ich ambitionierte junge Frauen? Hab ich auch unter meinen jungen Talenten, übersehe ich auch Frauen? Also dort auch schon ganz spezifisch diesen Blick zu haben, zu wissen, es gibt diesen Confirmation-Bias, denke ich vielleicht schon vorneherein, es sieht diese Frauen nicht, obwohl sie da sind. Und dann sich tatsächlich Ziele zu setzen. Also wir haben auch natürlich tauschen wir uns aus mit Menschen, die das für die deutsche Industrie, die dort solche Beratungen machen. Das ist unter anderem Barbara Lutz vom Frauenkarriereindex, FKI. Und die sagt immer, man hat dieses Ausgangspotenzial, also nehmen wir mal an, wir haben 30% Frauen auf den Einstiegsleveln, dann ist das mein Potenzial für den Vorstand. Aber ich muss gucken, dass ich sie halt über alle Ebenen bekomme. Ich darf sie halt nicht auf der Zwischenzeit verlieren. Und das passiert halt einfach. Also Orbert hat jetzt gerade einen Bericht rausgegeben für Kanzleien, für Großkanzleien. Einstieg ist 50 Prozent, oben als Partner kommen halt unter 20 Prozent an. Das ist nicht komplett exklusiv für den Fußball, sondern bestimmte Rahmenbedingungen erschweren das halt, dass das für Frauen machen. Und unter anderem wie gesagt dieser Confirmation-Bias ist ganz wichtig. Aber für mich ist das der Haupthebel, Frauen durchzuentwickeln. Und wenn wir dann auf die Positivbeispiele gucken, die wir auch im Bericht erwähnen, Kaisersleutern zum Beispiel mit über 40% Frauen auf den Direct-Reports-Ebenen, die haben auf fast komplett ihre, also Positionen mit Personalverantwortung, sind fast 70% von Frauen besetzt auf den Ebenen darunter. Und dann ist es auch leichter tatsächlich dann zu sagen, an diesem entscheidenden, dieser entscheidenden Klippe, okay, dann auch für die nächste Position. Und ich glaube, Anne Laufmann, sehr Geschäftsführerin bei Werder Bremen, sagt das auch ganz klar, dieses Wissen um die internen Vorgänge des Clubs, es ist ein wichtiger Schatz, den man hat und der halt wichtig ist, wenn du dann in diesen Räumen bist. Das ist das eine, also sozusagen das eine Best-Case-Szenario. Das andere Best-Case-Szenario sehen wir jetzt gerade bei TSG Hoffenheim. Die haben jetzt innerhalb von einem Jahr drei Positionen auf Geschäftsleitungsebene mit einer Frau besetzt. Und die IT-Frau hat eine Vergangenheit im Fußball, aber die Verantwortliche für Personal und die Verantwortliche für Kommunikation kommen jeweils aus anderen Branchen. Und es ist eine ganz bewusste Entscheidung, weil es halt, wie der CEO Marco Schütz sagt, dieses Unternehmen bereichert, diesen Club bereichert und dementsprechend auch neue Ziele möglich macht, die man halt vielleicht davor mit Menschen, die halt nur diesen Fußballhintergrund haben, gar nicht erreichen kann. Und ich glaube, beide Perspektiven zusammengedacht, wenn wir zusammen auf die Fußballbranche gucken, sind beide Wegemöglichkeiten und Fußballclubs können auch beide nehmen. Ich glaube, noch einmal aus diesem Allbright-Bericht, aus diesem Erfahrung Schütz zitiert, sagt Biebke Anker, ist eine der Geschäftsführerinnen, dass auch Unternehmen, die immer noch doppelt rot sind, also keine Frauen im Aufsichtsrat, keine Frauen im Vorstand, dann werden es zunehmend schwerer haben, Frauen für sich zu gewinnen. Und ich glaube, auch das ist ein Punkt, dass man, der einem bewusst sein muss, wenn man jetzt sagt, oh, bei uns bewerben sich gar keine Frauen, könnte an dem Club liegen. Also, es ist nicht so, dass man hinter sieben Bergen verborgen ist, sondern es ist nicht immer so für Frauen, sondern Frauen. Und das gilt dann wiederum auch noch für, wir haben vorhin gesagt, andere Vielfaltdimensionen, also auch queere Menschen, die gucken, natürlich, wie ist die Außendarstellung des Clubs. Finde ich dort auch schon Repräsentanten. Und wie gesagt, im Moment finden Frauen, die sich bei Clubs bewerben, bei vier Clubs solche Role Models auf dieser Ebene. Und es ist total wichtig. Und bei Werder zum Beispiel war das ganz entscheidend, dass Frauen da schon mal mit Anne Laufmann jemanden hatten, die schon mal klar auch zum Beispiel über das gesprochen hat, wie mache ich es eigentlich, dass ich zwei relativ kleine Kinder habe und Geschäftsführerin bin. Das ist einfach glaubwürdiges Leadership für dann auch Menschen, die sich dort bewerben wollen.
Ist es dann dahingehend, um dann quasi wieder auf die Ergebnisse des Berichts zurückzukommen, eine positive Nachricht, dass das Top-Management der Bereich ist, in dem wirklich am meisten rot grassiert, weil eben wirklich nur vier Clubs überhaupt eine Frau im Top-Management haben und bei allen anderen Kategorien, die ihr habt, also Aufsichtsräte, Kontrollgremien und dann eben diese Ebene, die direkt an die ausführende Top-Management-Ebene berichtet, also die Direct Reports, da wird es ja sukzessive besser. Ist das dann vielleicht Vorbote davon, dass eben nach diesem Nachwuchsgedanken, wir ziehen uns unsere Talente selbst von unten nach oben, dass es Raum und auch Möglichkeit zur Verbesserung gibt?
Ja, so haben wir uns auf jeden Fall dafür entschieden, so darauf zu blicken. Also wenn man sowas zum zweiten Mal macht, dann ist natürlich die Hoffnung, dass man dort Verbesserungen sieht. Uns ist aber auch klar gewesen, dass wir nicht dieses Bild innerhalb von einem Jahr ändern. Also das ist ja Expected Goals, würde ich sagen. Das war uns schon bewusst, dass wir keine komplette Kirtwände sehen werden. Aber es ist gut zu sehen, dass es tatsächlich, dass es diese Verbesserung gelingen kann. Also bei den Direct Reports Eintracht Frankfurt hat sich verbessert, Hoffenheim hat sich verbessert, St. Pauli hat sich verbessert und Leverkusen zum Beispiel, wie gesagt, die im letzten Jahr nicht mitgenommen haben, haben immerhin 25 Prozent Frauen auf dieser Ebene. Also das sind alles Zahlen, wo du sagst, okay, das ist eine Basis, mit der ihr als Club sehr gut arbeiten könnt und wo ihr auch seht, ihr habt diese Möglichkeit, euch zu verbessern. Ich glaube, der anderen Seite ist es bei diesen Direct Reports, wir haben ja auch die absoluten Zahlen jeweils in den Bericht geschrieben. Bei sehr vielen ist es halt die Zahl eins. Es gibt genau eine Frau auf dieser Ebene und dann sieht man natürlich auch, wie wackelig das Ganze ist, weil es gibt auch, im letzten Jahr waren es nur fünf Clubs, die halt auf dieser Ebene keine Frauen haben, in diesem Jahr sind es acht. Das sind tatsächlich zwei, die im letzten Jahr noch nicht Teil des Berichts waren, aber es sind halt auch darunter Clubs, die sich verschlechtert haben, weil sie ja genau diese eine Frau verloren haben. Und daran siehst du natürlich, das kann ja noch keine stabile Situation sein, wo du sagst, okay, alles gut, ihr habt eine Frau. Sondern da geht es halt darum, wie ich vorhin gesagt habe, die zweite, die dritte und halt auch wirklich stabile Wege zu finden, wie man halt diese Talente nicht verliert und wie man das halt auch im Blick behält, dass das eine Signalwirkung hat, ob du da eben diese Frauen in der Sichtbarkeit hast oder nicht.
Ihr habt das jetzt im Bericht selbst nicht abgebildet. Ich vermute, weil das wird dann auch zu klein zisilliert irgendwann. Aber habt ihr denn Erkenntnisse darüber, in welchen Aufgabenbereichen dann diese oft eine Frau tätig ist? Denn von außen geblickt, oberflächlich betrachtet, fällt mir auf, dass es in männerdominierten Branchen, das ist Marketing zum Beispiel auch oft zu sehen, oder bei Sportredaktionen. Du hast dann Frauen bei der Leitung des Büros, sage ich jetzt mal, oder zum Beispiel in der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit, in der Pressearbeit, im Marketing. Das sind ja tatsächlich auch die sichtbarsten Frauen, eben mit den Pressesprecherinnen, die wir zum Beispiel bei Männer Bundesligisten haben. Also habt ihr dazu auch Daten erhoben, die jetzt aber dann in der Zusammenfassung des Berichts nicht gelandet sind?
Nein, dazu haben wir keine Daten erhoben. Aber natürlich ist es so, bei 36 ist es ja gar nicht so. Wir arbeiten, das ist der Teil, der jetzt nicht bericht ist, aber wir arbeiten natürlich auch an der Vernetzung dieser Frauen und daran, die untereinander auch miteinander in Kontakt zu bringen, miteinander zu verknüpfen. Also fangen wir mal mit dem mit dem Nahelingsten an. Von den Clubs in der ersten Frauenbundesliga, die bei einem Männerclub angesiedelt sind, also die bei einem Bundesligisten organisiert sind. Das sind elf. Und von denen sind tatsächlich fast alle auf dieser Direct Reports-Ebene. Das heißt, und darunter sind anführungsweise nur drei Männer. Das heißt, das stellt schon mal, die stellen fast alle. Und das finde ich tatsächlich positiv, weil das war ja auch gar nicht unbedingt so. Wir haben in der Pressemitteilung jetzt zum Beispiel Bianca Recht zitiert, die Direktorin Frauenfußball beim FC Bayern. Da ist das seit 2024 so gelöst. Also seit Sommer 2024. Davor war es eine Abteilungsleitung. Jetzt ist es eine Direktion. Das ist schon ein erheblicher Unterschied in einem Unternehmen wie jetzt dem FC Bayern. Bei welchem der Entscheidung du direkt mit am Tisch sitzt. Das ist das Nahelingste, wo wir jetzt vielleicht auch nach der Euro drauf gucken können und sagen können, wie eng sind die dazu eingebunden. Ansonsten ist das nicht ganz querbeet. Es gibt viel Personalverantwortliche, die tatsächlich in diesem Direct Report sind. Also der Stuttgart zum Beispiel hat geteilte Personaldirektionen und eine davon ist eine Frau. Personal ist es viel und ansonsten ist es aber relativ querbeet, würde ich sagen. Je Sport näher es wird, umso herausfordernder ist es. Also wie gesagt, diese Sportdirektion oder auch der Sportvorstand ist immer ein Mann. Der Sportverantwortliche ist immer ein Mann und darunter ist es auch immer noch eine Abteilung, wo es am herausforderndsten ist. Also und weil das gleichzeitig das sichtbarste ist, ist das, glaube ich, auch einfach das dickste Brett, wo man irgendwie sagen kann, was wir, glaube ich, in diesem Jahr gesehen haben. Mit Sabrina Wittmann, das macht sehr viel für einen Club, sich in diesem Feld dafür zu entscheiden. Aber es ist nichts, wo man sofort, ja, was ganz schnell funktioniert.
Und gleichzeitig gibt es da eben auch so Grenzen des eigenen Denkens, so würde ich es jetzt mal nennen. Also die Frage ist ja schon gar nicht so leicht zu beantworten, warum zum Beispiel Bianca Rech nicht auch Sportverständin ist beim FC Bayern. Im ersten Moment scheint sie ganz schnell zu beantworten.
Wir wollen ihr keine Karriereziele geben, aber ich finde das auch super.
Genau, aber wenn man mal drüber nachdenkt, es sind zwei gleichberechtigte oder sollten gleichberechtigte Abteilungen sein. Frauen sind sogar erfolgreicher als die Männer gewesen in den letzten Jahren. Sie macht da sehr lange sehr gute Arbeit. Und das Interessante ist, im ersten Moment denkt man sich so, ja, nee, es ist ja viel weniger Umsatz, viel weniger Verantwortung, viel kleinere Abteilungen. Aber das nächste ist ja, Moment mal, aber warum entscheidet denn die Größe dessen, also, dass man nur so als Gedankenanstoß, vielleicht auch für die Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und Gedankenanstoß ist vielleicht auch das richtige Stichwort, denn es gibt immer mal wieder so Vereine, mit denen hätte zumindest ich nicht gerechnet. Also natürlich auch, weil ich mich mit dem Thema lange nicht so tief befasst habe, wie ihr bei Weitem nicht so tief. Aber gibt es denn auch für dich Vereine, wo du gedacht hast, ach, das hätte ich ja jetzt nie gedacht, wie gut die aufgestellt sind. Ich meine, Hoffenheim zum Beispiel, das hat man mitbekommen, wenn man ein Auge für diese Dinge hat. Weil Hoffenheim das auch mitkommensiert hat. Bei der Neubesetzung der Stellen wurde das ja, du hast ja vorhin Marke Schütz auch zitiert, wurde das ja extra mitbesprochen. Aber gab es auch Überraschungen für dich jetzt in diesem Bericht?
Also das ist tatsächlich, in diesem Jahr haben wir dann ja ein Interview geführt, aber im letzten Jahr war tatsächlich Kaiserslautern für mich eine Überraschung, weil man halt, da waren diese Directreports die bestplatzierten Elbersberg, Kaiserslautern und der FC Bayern. Der FC Bayern ist es jetzt in diesem Jahr nicht mehr. So, aber tatsächlich Elbersberg und Kaiserslautern sind total interessante Geschichten, wenn man sich das anguckt. Weil Elbersberg, um damit mal anzufangen, hat normalerweise, wer bewirbt sich bei Fußballklubs, es ist ganz viele Menschen, die diese Fußballklubs verehren. Also, die halt erstmal Fan sind und dann finden sie es total großartig, dort auch zu arbeiten. Das ist ein ganz, ja jetzt auch nicht übel zu bewährtenes Motiv, sondern ja durchaus nachvollziehbar, wenn man sich so stark identifiziert. Dieses Potenzial hat Elbersberg natürlich in zu viel geringerem Maße. Das heißt, die haben ihre Positionen viel normaler ausgeschrieben. Die haben einfach gesucht, wir suchen für den Bereich XY und Menschen, die sich dort beworben haben, haben sich vor allem aufgrund des Bereiches dafür beworben und für die Kompetenz und dann landest du bei einer Fassparität. Das ist schon wirklich interessant und dann auf der anderen Seite, also sozusagen diese Elbersberg als jetzt ja auch nicht mit einer ellenlangen Veranstaltung, auf der anderen Seite dieser wirklich buchstäbliche Traditionsgruppe Kaiserslautern, über den ich auch wirklich nicht viel wusste und jetzt in dem Interview mit der Personalchefin Julia Martin erfahren habe, da passen verschiedene Dinge zusammen. Also unter anderem, dass da fast 40 Prozent oder mehr als 40 Prozent Frauen im Stadion sind. Das heißt, was mir schon nicht unbedingt bewusst war, das ist ja eine fast Rekordzahl, würde ich mal denken, die kaum einen sonst einen Club erreicht. Das heißt, dieses Abstrahlen dieser Arbeitgebermarke funktioniert für Frauen wie Männer. Man hat in dem Talentpool, die sich bewerben, nicht nur Männer, was bei vielen anderen Clubs tatsächlich die Herausforderung ist unter den Bewerbungen. Dann zweitens auch durchaus die wirtschaftliche Krise, wo die ein paar Männer verloren haben, die dann halt zu größeren Clubs gegangen sind. Und das heißt, da hat dann in dieser Zeit der Drittliga die Menschen in der zweiten Reihe, und das waren oft Frauen, die die Möglichkeit bekommen, dann diese Abteilung zu leiten. Es ist dann zwar leider hart, aber es ist so in der Krise. Das ist auch immer eine ganz gute Zeit für Frauen, muss man sagen. Und dann halt das Dritte zu sagen, okay, es gibt für uns gar keinen Bereich, bei dem wir denken, das kann nicht eine Frau machen. Sie haben jetzt zum Beispiel im letzten Jahr neu besetzt die Stadion-Organisation mit einer Frau. Also Stadionbetrieb. Das ist wirklich ein, sie leitet jetzt glaube ich ein Team mit sechs oder sieben Männern. Aber halt einfach zu sagen, ja, ist so. Und das ist glaube ich, wie wir gesagt haben, ist das ganz viel auch Kopfsache. Und war für mich wirklich inspirierend zu hören und zu sagen, okay, ja, so geht das auch. So das sind eben und dann, wenn man halt guckt, das sind ganz unterschiedliche Wege. Das sind auch ganz unterschiedliche Konzepte. Und natürlich handelt der Bericht auch viel von Best Cases, die bei St. Pauli stattfinden. Das ist einfach tatsächlich ein Club, der auf sehr vielen Ebenen Dinge getan hat. Unter anderem, du hast ja schon gesagt, eine Quote sich zu geben für die Gremien. Aber eben auch, was wir auch in dem Bericht erzählen, zum Beispiel diese Position im Präsidium in Teilhauptamtlichkeit auszuschreiben. Das heißt, diese Frauen werden dafür zum Teil bezahlt. Das hilft auch, wenn du irgendwie denkst, wen bekommst du vielleicht für diese Ehrenamtspositionen und wen bekommst du nicht. Bekommst du halt viel auch eigentlich Männer am Ende ihrer Karriere. Wenn du aber halt dieses Innovationspotenzial willst, dann brauchst du ja Frauen, die mitten in ihrer Karriere stehen. Und dafür ist es dann, finde ich, eine Überlegung wert zu sagen, okay, ist nicht auch eine Option für uns, die zu bezahlen für ihre Arbeit dort.
Und wisst ihr, ob das bei weiteren Vereinen noch in Planung ist? Also wie sind die Reaktionen auf eure Umfrage und dann auch auf den Bericht und eben die Gespräche, die die Vereine mit euch führen können?
Also ich habe ja schon gesagt, für uns war wirklich gut zu sehen, dass wir jetzt dieses Bild vollständig zeigen konnten. Das heißt, es waren auch viele noch mal Gespräche im Vorfeld und wir haben in dem Bericht, wir veröffentlichen ja 31.07., haben ihn veröffentlicht 31.07. Und die Tage davor haben wir sie schon an die Clubs geschickt, damit die auch eine Möglichkeit haben, falls dann auch Journalisten und Journalistinnen nachfragen, halt die Zahlen schon vorliegen zu haben. Und da sind die Reaktionen, wie gesagt, ich glaube natürlich ein bisschen immer auch O. Also, ups, will ich nicht sagen, O stimmt schon eher. Aber natürlich, wie gesagt, in diesem Ranking, sich dann dort auch in einem Bereich zu sehen, wo man nicht gerne ist, das ist irgendwas, was einen, ja, was einen, glaube ich, wenn man diese Zahlen sieht, auch frustriert. Und auf der anderen Seite bin ich auch froh, dass wir, zum Beispiel in der Pressemitteilung jetzt Alex Werle, den CEO von Stuttgart, mit dem Quot dran haben, dass er sagt, er will sich dem noch stärker annehmen. Also, es ist, glaube ich, eigentlich die sportlich richtige Reaktion. Nicht zu sagen, weil man ja in allen anderen Feldern von Fußball agiert, man ja so, man guckt, man zieht eine Bilanz und dann setzt man sich neue Ziele. Also, das ist eigentlich die Haltung, die einem auch in diesem Feld weiterbringt.
Und aus welchem, also welches Argument glaubst du zieht da eher? Das Argument, dass man sagt, schauen sie mal Club XY, lieber Herr so und so. Es gibt diese, diese, diese und diese Studie. Und nach denen ist nachgewiesen, dass eben diverser besetzte Unternehmen wirtschaftlich besser dastehen. Oder zieht das Argument, schauen sie mal Herr so und so, sie stehen übrigens auf Platz 17, weil sie keine einzige Frau im Kontrollgremium haben. Das sieht doch schon ganz schön schlecht aus.
Also ich, ich finde ganz gut, dass man da so einen ganzen Werkzeugkasten präsentieren kann, ehrlich gesagt, weil Menschen, auch wenn sie alle im Fußball arbeiten, sind nicht alle gleich. Und was sie jeweils motiviert zu diesem Wandel sind durchaus unterschiedliche Dinge. Also ich glaube manchmal auch so ein bisschen ja, vielleicht stolz auf, auf die Frau, die man dann da schon mal durchbegleitet hat, was zwar nur persönlich subjektiv ist, aber auch für mich legitim und okay. Und wenn wir uns jetzt wiederum mal diese 100 Personen angucken, die sind im Schnitt halt westdeutsch, sie sind um die 50, sie haben 50 oder etwas älter, sie haben eher einen wirtschaftswissenschaftlichen Hintergrund. Also die sind schon relativ homogen in dem, wer sie sind, was sie sind, wo sie davor waren. Insofern muss diese Gruppe sich auch untereinander unterhalten, weil das ist wiederum diese Peer Group, ist das, was am stärksten funktioniert. Deshalb bin ich froh, jetzt ist Fernando Caro nicht deutsch, insofern das ist schon mal eine dieser Merkmale, die ihn da outzingelt. Aber Alex Werle, Axel Hellmann, Fernando Caro, ich hoffe, dass die diese Sätze auch dann in Runden sagen, wo halt tatsächlich keine andere Frau anwesend ist, weil das sind die Räume, in denen das als kollektive Aufgabe angegangen werden muss. Und ich glaube, dann gibt es auch unterschiedliche Perspektiven noch darauf. Also Axel Hellmann in dem Bericht sagt auch sehr stark, er glaubt, dass das auch Bottom-up-Impulse geben muss. Also das heißt, dass die Vereine, die den Profifußball zugeordnet sind, die den tragen, dass auch aus diesen Bereichen diese Impulse kommen müssen. Das haben wir uns in diesem Jahr auch ein bisschen damit beschäftigt. Und man sieht durchaus da auch Entwicklung. Der HSV hat sich jetzt im Juni, die nennen das nicht Quote, Vielfalt Ziele gegeben für ihre Gremien. Du siehst tatsächlich immer mehr Aussichtsräte sind nicht mehr rein rot. Schalke hat jetzt nach dem Berichtszeitraum jetzt Steffi Jones kooptiert. Also das heißt, dorthin entsandt, ohne dass sie durch den Wahlprozess gegangen ist. Die Option gibt es auch. Also es ist, glaube ich, von oben in den Räumen von unten diese Bewegung tut gut daran, dass man sich nicht nur auf eins verlässt, sondern tatsächlich ganz viele unterschiedliche Wege probiert.
Und dann gibt es irgendwann auch mal die anderen Beispiele. Ich meine, man könnte jetzt zum Beispiel auch über die DFL noch sprechen als Vertretung der Vereine. Da haben wir jetzt gerade zwei Männer am Ruder. Und wir hatten aber kurz eine Frau mit Donata-Hopfen, wo man zumindest von ganz außen betrachtet den Eindruck hatte, so schnell wie das dann zu Ende ging, auch wenn es nach allem, was man hört, sicherlich auch inhaltliche Gründe gab. Aber ob das bei einem Mann genauso, ich sag mal kurz und schmerzlos gegangen wäre, diese Zeit wieder zu beenden, ich persönlich möchte es einfach mal so dahingestellt lassen. Mein Eindruck war, dass da besonders, besonders schnell gegen Donata-Hopfen dann wieder nicht mehr als Chefin der DFL zu haben. Aber das sind ja dann vielleicht auch noch mal andere Themen, obwohl es dasselbe Thema ist. Aber ihr konzentriert euch ja jetzt erst mal hier auf die Vereine.
Ich glaube, es ist total wichtig, das finde ich schon, dass man auch, dass diese Frauen in diesen Positionen, weil wie gesagt, wir haben ja schon gesagt, das sind nicht furchtbar viele, also Aufsichtsräte, die Aufsichtsrätinnen sind es unter 30, dass diese Frauen in den Austausch miteinander gehen, dass wir Netzwerke organisieren, dass es dort tatsächlich praktizierte Solidarität gibt. Weil ich glaube, je exponierter du bist, und das ist letztlich fast noch jede dieser Frauen, das ist wichtig, umso mehr brauchst du den Zusammenhalt. Und das ist tatsächlich von Anfang an die Idee von Fußball und das hat nicht eine Frau gegründet, sondern es haben neun Frauen gegründet. Und es ist auch nach wie vor das, was unsere Arbeit ausmacht, diese Frauen zusammenzubringen, in den Austausch miteinander zu bringen, auch in den Austausch zu bringen mit tatsächlich progressiv denkenden Männern. Und ich glaube, das ist total wichtig, damit du eben nicht dieses Gefühl hast, von ich bin da alleine auf weiter Flur, was ich einstellen kann im Fußball nach wie vor.
Und das wäre jetzt nämlich dann auch meine abschließende Frage an dich gewesen. Ich vermute, jetzt beginnt für dich persönlich eine arbeitsreiche Zeit. Ich hoffe, viele öffentliche Auftritte und Medienanfragen und so weiter. Aber was sehen denn jetzt die nächsten Wochen erstmal für dich vor? Und was wird Fußball kann mehr jetzt dann in der nächsten Zeit alles angehen?
Also wir, in der Tat, der Bericht ist ja, also ich bin von Haus aus Journalistin insofern und hatte schon immer das Problem, dass ich Produkte immer nicht so klein halten kann. Insofern, dieser Bericht hat ja 50 Seiten. Insofern, bis, und ich finde wichtig, dass der so perspektivenreich ist, insofern diese ganzen Perspektiven vorzustellen über unsere Social Media Kanäle, das ist vor allem LinkedIn und im Newsletter, ist wichtig für uns auch tatsächlich diese ganzen unterschiedlichen Frauen und Männer zu Wort kommen zu lassen. Und dann haben wir ein größeres Event, was wir planen, am 2. Oktober den Hamburg Sports Summit, was wir im letzten Jahr zum ersten Mal gemacht haben, während der Männer Euro, wo wir uns damit beschäftigen, wie passiert eigentlich Veränderung. Und dann als ein Fokusthema werden wir im nächsten Jahr nach wie vor das Thema Recruitment haben. Weil, wie gesagt, das sind diese Hebel, die halt längst noch nicht gut funktionieren. Nochmal gesagt, wie gesagt, 19 neue Besetzung, eine Frau. Das heißt, wir müssen uns damit beschäftigen, welche Talente kommen in den Fußball, ins Fußballmanagement und welche kommen da nicht hin. Welche Managerinnen kommen da nicht hin. Und uns damit zu beschäftigen und dafür mit den Klubs zusammen tragbare Modelle zu erarbeiten, das ist einer der Fokusthemen meiner Arbeit.
Dann sind wir sehr gespannt, wie sich das alles weiterentwickelt. Und ich kann den Bericht wirklich sehr empfehlen, gerade weil ihr ihn so umfangreich gemacht habt, weil da eben auch Interviews drin sind und so weiter, liest es ehrlich gesagt eher wie ein Magazin. Also, deswegen grämen dich nicht, dass er über 50 Seiten hat. Ich werde ihn verlinken. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ist euch sehr ans Herz gelegt. Es ist wirklich interessant, gerade die Interviews dann zu lesen und nochmal quasi die, ist auch interessant, dann die Gesichter und Persönlichkeiten zu der Zahl, zur Ziffer 1 zu bekommen, die man oft im Bericht sieht. Ehrlicherweise ist das doch ein bisschen tragisch. Also, ein bittesüßer Witz, aber irgendwie dann doch nett. Also, ich werde ihn verlinken. Julia, vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank für deine Zeit. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wo es noch hingeht, denn der Fußball kann mehr. Jetzt muss er es halt auch mal zeigen. Danke dir.
Ich danke dir.
Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern, denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe-und-sponsoren-frei. Alles, was wir hier machen, ist von euch finanziert auf rasenfunk.de. Da findet ihr unter Unterstützen-Button, wie man uns finanzielle Unterstützung zukommen lassen kann. Geht per Dauerauftrag, per Paypal, bei Kreditkarte, bei Überweisung. Vielen herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. Und wenn ihr Feedback habt zu dieser Folge oder zu anderen, dann geht es sehr gerne auf mitmachen.rasenfunk.de oder schreibt uns in einem sozialen Netzwerk eure Wahl. In diesem Sinne, bleibt gesund, bleibt uns gewogen und bis bald. Ciao!
Das war der Rasenfunk, von Ihnen unterstützt, herzlichen Dank.